Oh like a sieve what do you think of
shortcrust pastry it's sort of semi
flaky but it's rich buttery start by
sifting 200 grams of plain flour into a
mixing bowl large pinch of salt 200
grams of unsalted butter bring the
butter up to room temperature if you let
the butter become too soft then the
flour so it doesn't absorb it in your
fingers rub together first now the
secret is grab big handfuls and squeeze
the butter into the flour so look what's
happened littering 30 seconds I've got
that nice crumbly texture now cover
tablespoons of water nothing worse when
the pastry is so wet you can't bring it
together needs to shape like a nice rich
cookie dough is just a touch too dry so
one more tablespoon of water
oh yeah it's coming nicely now that's
what I want a nice sort of firm ball
pastry onto the board I'm gonna use
these when the strongest parts of the
body pull towards you and push back down
use those wrists to really need it
together so just that nice sort of
smooth texture
now wrap it in cling film set down the
fridge 20 minutes really important then
you let the shortcrust pastry relaxed
now to make the quiche you can use just
an ordinary flan dish but I love making
them in mini frying pans which give them
an extra rustic charm brush with oil to
stop the pastry from sticking
once the pastry is at room temperature
roll it out to a nice even thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want any holes in
this just get a little bit of dough
cause that sort of acts like a little
sort of mallet sends it out nicely
I'm building a sort of extra lip is that
way I can get a filling and there's
absolute maximum levels when I cook them
blind first
the blind-bake simply means to precook
your pastry before adding the filling
this ensures you'll have a fantastic
crisp pastry add a sheet of foil or
baking paper and weigh it down
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking stones just make sure you keep
them for the next time and feel them 200
degrees for 10 minutes now for the
filling I'll do a classic quiche bacon
and links this is a amazing cured
pancetta pancetta is an Italian cured
meat made from belly pork seasoned with
things like juniper nutmeg fennel a
great substitute is unsmoked bacon as
Ivan cheddar gets lovely and crispy
finely sliced leeks and add well leeks
and bacon nice really important to cook
those links down it's exactly what I
want
cuz leave almost sort of camel eyes
slightly crispy the flavors amazing I
just drain them off so any excess fat
gets drained cut the tablespoons of
cream it gives it pretty nice richness
I want two-thirds garnish I eat bacon
and length in my quiche and one-third of
the savory custard touch of salt touch a
pepper my great sangria cheese that
makes a really nice sort of creamy less
of an eggy quiche take my amazing crispy
pancetta and leeks in hmm give it a good
mix needs one more little thing some
freshness flat leaf parsley incredible
really important just to taste
mmm
the mixture with the quiche filling
ready next finish off the pastry remove
the fallen weights and return to the
oven to get it lovely and golden all
over now when we fill them give that a
really good mix up
beautiful great over some more cheese
which will bubble up and melt
beautifully then into the oven
make your keys for 15 to 20 minutes
incredible it's got that nice sort of
cheese on toast mouth on the top it's
sort of bait the secret of any good
quiche is in the short crust because
that's the hero
one nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin because sliders are
bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big